a new year new arrivals and a new plan
by President Joe Biden aimed at slowing
the rising tide of migrants trying to
enter the U.S illegally today my
Administration is taking several steps
to stiffen enforcement for those who try
to come without a legal right to stay
and to put in place a faster process
emphasize a faster process to decide a
claim of Asylum the new measure would
create a legal albeit narrow pathway for
the growing number of Cubans nicaraguans
and Haitians making their way North up
to 30 000 migrants a month those with
sponsors and who pass background checks
will be allowed into the U.S to live and
to work for two years but they will have
to travel by plane if they try to
smuggle themselves in by land or by sea
and get caught they will be barred the
numbers of illegal migrants has exploded
in recent years particularly at the land
border states like California Texas
Arizona saw more than 2.7 million
arrivals last year way up from the 2021
number of 1.9 million we anticipate this
action is going to substantially reduce
the number of people attempting
attempting to cross our Southwest border
without going through a legal process
this week the arrival of hundreds of
migrants from Cuba forced the closure of
a national park of the coast of Florida
on Thursday they were moved to the U.S
mainland
in another measure aimed at reducing the
number of illegal migrants the U.S has
just resumed
services in Cuba it's hoping more people
will follow this legitimate route
instead if you are in a burning building
it does not seem right to say but before
you jump from the second floor please go
to your computer get online schedule an
interview go to the consulate come back
to the burning building wait for a
couple of months and then you can jump
right when somebody has to flee to be
alive they have to flee and our systems
have to honor and recognize that context
the new policy has the land border
firmly in its sights but in Florida
where the border is at the water the
question is how will it work here
Florida's Republican Governor has made
it very clear where he stands on illegal
migration Ron DeSantis hasn't just
spoken out against it he has actively
helped other Republican states move
migrants to democratic areas remember
this is a man who although he hasn't
formally said it yet is widely expected
to declare a run for presidency in 2024.
if that does happen expect a lot more
Focus On the Border particularly the
maritime Border in the coming months
Phil Lavelle Al Jazeera Miami